يا له من خبر سعيد
فالاطفال كانت مصابه بفيروس نقص المناعه
المكتسبه اتش اي في في ولايه
ميسيسيبي انه خبر مفرح من كل النواحي
فالامر حدث بسلاسه ودون كلفه
طائله علاج الطفله اتسم الى حد ما بالحظ
فوالده الطفله كانت مصابه بفيروس اتش اي
في موجب وقامت بنقله لطفلتها وعليه اعطيت
الطفله علاجا مضادا للفيروس الا ان
والدتها توقفت عن اعطائها اياه عند بلوغها
15 شهرا وعادت لزياره الطبيب عند بلوغها
الثانيه من عمرها واظهرت الفحوصات انها
خاليه من الفيروس رغم انها لم تاخذ الدواء
لاكثر من ثمانيه
اشهر انه خبر سعيد لا اعتقد ان احدا كان
يتوقع ذلك وقد يكون السبب هو ان الطفله
تلقت جرعات عاليه من ثلاث ادويه مضاده
للمرض منذ ولادتها اذ ان اغلب الاطفال
المصابين ب روس اش اي في موجب يحصلون على
جرعات منخفضه واذا امكن علاج اطفال اخرين
خلال 15 شهرا فقط فان ذلك سيكون تقدما
علميا مميزا لان الاطفال المصابين بش اي
في موجب ياخذون عاده العلاج لمدى الحياه
وقد يكون ساما هذا ولا تزال هناك حاجه
للمزيد من الدراسات لهذا العلاج الا ان
هذه الحاله قد تكون قد فتحت المجال امام
العديد من الاطفال المرضى لمنحهم فرصه
لمستقبل افضل